welcome to this video a new video in the
series chess Giants presenting great
games from the past and this is some a
little bit different than the first two
games that I presented in this series
this is not a direct attacking game but
a strategic masterpiece by Anatoly
Karpov it's a well known game but it's
one of those games some yeah if you know
it good for you if you don't know it
you're about to experience an absolute
classic and you will know it after
watching the video okay let's get it
this was played against Wolfgang
WindSeeker the back then the German top
player we're talking about the year 1974
this game was played in them Chess
Olympiad yeah
40 years ago back then cup of I was not
world champion yet but he was I think he
already was the Challenger in 1974 I
probably had already won the match
against scholarship okay let's see what
happened here wins they kept playing 1e5
as he usually did he was a very
classical player double King pawn was
his normal defense
okay we got a reuleaux pass cap off
almost exclusively played him the
Spanish opening the way only very rarely
did he play something like the Italian
game I don't think he did anything else
really
I don't think he played the scotch but
the Roy this was his domain and he had a
fantastic score with it in fact Karpov
had an excellent score with one eform
all of his career up to one point when
he started to play Kasparov for the
World Championship match Kasparov really
had such excellent knowledge and an feel
for the night off it basically forced
couple to give up one e-form for those
matches and this also meant that he
started to switch to default type of
positions more and more if it
I wasn't formed this a specific case the
matches against Kasparov in the night of
a think help of would have probably
continued to play 1.e4 yeah we got him
closed we Lopez iam has done in
thousands of games and T at one second
goes for Knight a5 the old chigorin
variation probably the oldest way to
play this it's a bit wood fashioned
maybe you could call it that nowadays
but still a very very valid line um
especially the approach that wouldn't
secure places old-fashioned I must I
must add nowadays the most popular moves
are a Bishop d7 the site's F or 98 also
moves at table of players black cup of
didn't play Knight a5 that often in
comparison yeah Bishop c2 n c5 this is
the basic and most important idea of the
chicken it immediately sets the C pawn
in motion in other lines let's say after
this should be seven this is not so easy
to accomplish here the C pawn takes a
while to get into the game after d4 for
example or not for example after the
fourth white puts pressure only five so
you cannot easily move the knight
somewhere and then move the C pawn
Knight f5 really takes this chance to
involves the C pawn in the fight for the
center D for Queen c7 9 BD - yeah this
is also played nowadays but now once I
could play some somewhat old-fashioned
line and in fact I know a little bit
about it because I play that myself
sometimes like knight c6 this is some
quite unpopular nowadays because because
it leads to somewhat passive positions
nowadays people mostly play it like that
where black is getting the safe
to play on and this leads to entirely
different positions after 96 the most
promising move for white is d5 leading
to a close center the main problem that
black has is this night it now
theoretically speaking could go to b8
but after that white emploice is typical
we move a 4 and this means that black
needs to respond with some awkward move
now if you don't really want to play
Bishop b7 looking at the d5 pawn and
yeah well what what exactly are you
playing now the night is not very well
placed then he went to d8 one second did
this in fact looks even more ridiculous
at first but it does have some idea
quite strangely enough he didn't follow
up on this idea and this is one reason
why he got into into this trouble in the
game yeah I can tell you this idea and
later and we see it pretty quickly
a4 rook b8 a4 is a normal move in the
rule or pass you want to nibble at this
pawn and the typical reaction of rupee 8
which is the best move leads to a
situation where white enjoys the open a
file the open a file in fact will become
a main main strategic element of this
game yeah what should white play now cup
of now played the absolute best move I
believe I have some experience as
mentioned in the structure and Capas
move is by far the most testing he went
before him yeah why is before good news
the the main reason is that establishing
opponent before plays against this night
on d8 if the night at some point goes to
b7 and in fact he does that right now
which I believed to be is a mistake
then we see that this pawn is
controlling those two key squares the
Knight has nowhere to go here for can go
back but it's coming from the eight and
this is one point of the before the
second point is it fixes this pawn on a
light square very often black will be
young forced tempted whatever to advance
c4 and those pawns on light squares can
sometimes be attacked by white for
example night b1 a3 attacking b5 just
one way to do it yeah what should like
do as mentioned once again played night
b7 and I don't think that this really is
a good idea what black should do here is
either play c4 as I normally do when I
get to the position I must say that I
only played this line in with four black
you know the black in blitz anymore
because while there I at least know the
the middle games very well and can play
quickly when tournament chess is to pass
affirm from my taste
yeah well see form what black wants to
do is he wants to reposition his knights
the knight on the 8th who wants to go to
f7 mm-hmm
you have to have 7 the ideas let's say
what does something like that like is
going for a setup like this yeah if we
just put some moves on the board I want
to demonstrate what like is aiming for
now the knight has completed a journey
d8 c6 d 8f 7 and then f7 it does a
pretty good defensive job
it protects important squares and it's
not in the way of any other piece it
sometimes prepares ideas like a bishop
f8 to h6 to exchange the dark squared
bishop very long-term plan but the most
important thing is it's not in the way
the knight on b7 as in second plate is
really heading nowhere
it will actually yeah be it would be
will obstruct blacks pieces top of know
when night everyone
the typical regrouping Bishop e7 and
Bishop III a very logical set up to play
Bishop III and now Queen d2 note that
like when Toluca eight to now play for
the Haifa
this is certainly the right idea but it
needs to be followed upon with the right
continuation how should black play now
WindSeeker played a very em up face
looking he played rook F to c8 what's
the general idea of the move yeah what
black wants to do is he wants to put the
Queen on the eighth rank and then trade
on a1 and play rook yet again so it's a
little bit like yeah arranging your
pieces form a straight up on the iPhone
the idea was perfectly right but it was
executed in a less favorable way what
black should have done it you should've
played rook F to be eight the difference
is very subtle but there is one after
this we should be three black to play
Queen c8 and now we will get this piece
trading on the iPhone it's still it's
more comfortable comfortable for white
disposition but it it is a very
resilient position and not easy to break
down in the game he didn't manage due to
some very nice maneuvers rook fc8 as
mentioned was played in the game of
course black is now threatening to take
on before the c2 pond SC to Bishop is
saying so why it went Bishop to d3
yeah now one cigar played the move g6
and after night g3 he went Bishop f8 if
he tries to complete this regrouping
that I said to exchange on the fr28 the
problem is that after those straights
all of a sudden the e5 pawn is a
weakness and white wins an important
central pawn that's the difference to
the setup with rook b8 and queen on c8
we just go back Luke b8 to shove d3
Queen c8 for example 93 then here B
takes Knight takes the Queen is an
additional protector of e5 very subtle
but this was enough to get one secured
into deep trouble as mentioned this was
played
yeah and now Karpov begins to fight for
the fo Luke a - that's a strong move
intending rook a one this gives white
control over the a foul
black must react what should you do one
possible idea would be to trade and then
try to go for count to play like that
this looks nice at first but if you take
a closer look after Queen b1 the black
Queen is not doing very much it is well
it's looking at the before pawn but
Weiss first and foremost friends to kick
the Queen back like a group c8 yeah it
can easily happen that after Queen a3
rooks e1 we got more pieces traded check
and here we see an additional benefit of
her from having played before with 92
coming to see three white is
pressurizing the b5 pond due to his
superior space and better peace
coordination he can far more easily
attack and pressurize the b5 pond then
black can't do anything remotely
comparable to the beaver pond yeah he
has no piece to attack this pawn so b5
is much much weaker than before so this
is just a very nice position for white
black does not really benefit from from
those trades yeah what he tried as he
played c4 oops
c4 trying to this way yeah disrupted the
coordination of White's pieces cup of
plate a very interesting move now I
played to Bishop to be one
the idea is revered soon afterwards
Queen d8 now is played again initiating
the idea to play rook takes a - Andrew
Gaede yeah now caps the move that made
this game so famous and yeah it has been
yeah how can I say this is a this is a
very famous motif that has been used
after this game and tons of times
because people came aware of it and sort
of yeah
they they looked for four possibilities
to play it cap off now played the very
very nice move Bishop to e7 which at
first looks a bit crazy why would you
put it on a his heaven yeah the idea is
just that what white wants to avoid is
that black relieves the pressure by
exchanging looks with Bishop e7 he
places a piece on the FR
and just prevents any further exchanges
from happening this is just a very nice
way to keep the pressure on if you have
more space you want to keep your space
advantage and keep pieces on the board
and not allow too many pieces to be
traded off and this is accomplished by
this great move very often in very
closed positions you need to find those
subtle points to really increase your
advantage without the move white is not
having very much with it yeah once again
is basically due to passivity here he
played tonight to e8 it's not very nice
Bishop C 297 rook a 1 here we go white
now has occupied the FO Queen e7 and
Bishop to be one yeah coordinating as
best as possible we should be eight yeah
it does not look great what black is
doing but what exactly is his plan he
can really just sit and wait what cap
off now wants to do is he wants to gain
even more space yeah and it's very often
the case when you dominate on one part
of the board one side you will very
often try to make progress on the other
side as well and this is now initiated
92 nine back to the eight nine h2 and
here we go the F pawn is set into motion
at first this looks am a bit risky
because well black might be able to to
use the long diagonal with this Bishop
that's true but it also creates an
important change in the structure that
is beneficial for white after the
capture and this is what really blacks
should have done he didn't play that and
this is really
yeah I think a big practical mistake
really he should have taken and what I'm
getting at is after white recaptures on
f4 and now we are what should black play
so it's very difficult the UH Nets a
place might be seven back then white is
coming to deform this is what I was
getting at with the e5 pawn gone white
has gained the default square for his
pieces this can be a knight this can
also be a bishop bishop to deform can be
a good idea at the right right moment
this is very very advantageous for white
also because of the fact that in the
position here after the capture black
really really really wants a knight only
five but it's very difficult to get a
knight down if you want to really force
it the only way to do it is to start
with f6 which again kills your Bishop
and will also lead to very nice position
for white yeah for example Knight f3
knight of seven Knight d4 and white has
an excellent position he's got a six as
an outpost c6 as an outpost and he's
always putting pressure on the b5 phone
it's a very nice position when secure
ever played the move f6 yeah stay
staying staying passive and yeah cap off
uses his mischance he to gain even more
space with f5 it's getting yeah
more and more cramped for black here
black has a choice and I think he
probably should have taken on f5 it's
nothing that you love to play that's
clear but what he played I think is
pretty much the same as giving up um I
think black should take and try to fight
from here
why does of course much better but it's
still
yeah something that you can can you
continue to fight
note that this transformation in the
pawn structure has given white now an
additional asset the e4 square this
could be a good square for a knight for
example on the other hand maybe black
has some possibilities yeah rook h8
something to g8 yeah it's a long time
but it does not feel so passive as in
the game in the game he played g5 just
trying to absolutely yeah batten down
the hatches and try to survive this
however it is as passive as it gets
how does white continue now we now see a
very nice maneuver by Karpov and this is
the second very impressive and very
instructional moment of this game yeah
how can white improve his position it's
all very nice on the fr but how do you
make any progress if you are unsure what
to do it's very often a good idea to
look at your worst piece what's the
worst piece it's their way to improve
the worst piece or exchange the worst
piece for a good piece of the opponent
and this is a key principle that cap off
now uses he plays Bishop c2 the idea of
the movies C 2 D 1 h5 trade this Bishop
against Blacks Bishop the LightSquared
Bishop this would mean a huge progress
for white and black really has no way to
prevent that he threated is speaking
could have played h5 now but this does
not help him very much
for example after this he is ultimately
forced to move the H pawn and this at
the end will also
yeah d2s defeat white now has the G
Foursquare for the night and will
certainly be able to open up the
position at the right moment with g3
it's really not helping and much he went
Bishop f7 and now Karpov continued with
this idea
93 Knight b7 Bishop t1 exchanging that
stupid-looking bishop on h5 h6 and
Bishop age 5
yeah if black plays something like Queen
e8 to cover this for the moment this is
not nothing that that helps for very
long white can just increase the control
over the edge v square and get the trade
in anyway yeah he went h6
not helping very much weakening the
light squares even more but it's very
hard to to give them any advice bishop
h5 queen d1 keeping control over h5 with
the trade of the light squared bishop we
make sure that blacks light squares are
terminally weak
this is also why h6 wasn't a very very
great move but as mentioned it is
basically not defensible anymore black
now played 98 and now half of very
slowly improves this position he has all
the time in the world
Luke a3 yeah the ideas that rooks on a3
and a2
a little bit better than a 2 and on a1
and maybe white can use the idea queen
a1 we see that here here white white may
play Queen a1 if he desires he might
switch over the rope here it's just a
little bit better than having the rooks
on a1 and a2 we have time yeah like it's
marking time is why I cannot do anything
takes my plate
94 sorry 94 yeah of course black cannot
win any material here Jack as he loses
the Queen King of age 93 yeah regrouping
this night to a to a good active square
check no the trade the Queen no Queen
now join to join the action and yeah it
gets harder and harder if who black to
do anything
98 most played now yeah what what else
is there black ant tribe night to h8 if
he wants trying to cover the g6 gram
yeah here the most
yeah are the simplest way to continue is
it some just to capture or 94 yeah 94 is
also nice 94 Queen takes Knight takes
very nice f6 King f7 must be played what
a sorry position here of the night
Bishop to b6
and this now leads to a very amusing
position as black as a total Zeus man he
cannot move the night this night also
cannot move if you move the bishop he
will lose they have six pawn and if 6f6
is attacked three times and it cannot be
defended enough so white is completely
winning this very funny position
I played night two to d8 which is quite
quite comparable yeah queen g6 now has
played one of the moves that led to win
the game it's a little bit yeah it's a
little bit like saying to black valve in
age six it wasn't very good
but there were there were many ways to
to conclude now black plate came to f8
now and now Knight h5 force plate it's
really funny after 44 months we have
reached a position where just the a
pawns have been traded the position is
otherwise closed now there's only the
LightSquared bishop exchanged if you
look at the pieces and still with the
board completely yeah full of pieces
black now resigned
there is absolutely no defense IAM we
can look at some amusing lines if you
like let's say black trades wide
recaptures and it's very hard now for
black to even make a move let's say 97
let me go here 98 keeping g7 protected
yeah
and now it gets very very difficult for
black to even move anything group is 6
yeah and we are close
we're very close to Zuke's 1 black is
breaking down let's say rook e8 would be
6
ropm and we start to collect collect
pawns it's just a terribly terribly
uncoordinated position
yeah Queen takes g6 it doesn't really
help and if he just stays here with the
Queen then Knight g4 provides a further
pressure on those weaknesses age six f6
and so on ninety-eight Bishop e6 for
example is enough to to seal the deal
takes takes and again black s very
hard-pressed to find any move that he
that he can play yeah a very very nice
game and one of cup of real classics if
we go back to to see some key ideas yeah
black IAM employed rather passive set up
a set up that does not really yeah allow
for from many inaccurate moves Knight b7
is the first of those slightly
inaccurate moves if you want to play a
set of a c4 you should do it right away
by the way maybe 98 is a possible idea
here for black to avoid the the general
structure with with the closed centre
yeah 97 is the first step in the wrong
direction and the next next important
point was that this wasn't a precise
move rook FP 8 Quincy 8 was better and
here the main problem was that black
didn't see this Bishop a7 idea he
thought that he would be able to trade
rooks to get yeah to get some relief for
his position by by trading but Bishop e7
prevented all that and with black being
paralyzed on the Queen side white could
open the second front on the Kings side
after black allowed this structure white
now found the nice maneuver with this
Bishop trade it off and then invade on
the light squares yeah and at the end it
was almost Zuke's one black couldn't
really move anything and was totally
paralyzed yeah a total classic ever
count off yeah I hope you enjoyed the
game even if you knew it already oh I'd
seen it before I still think it's it's
worth to look at if it was new to you I
hope you enjoyed it even more thanks for
watching